encore prison dorée ils ont conquis leur
public grâce à un bouche à oreille
efficace
ils remplissent les salles avec leur
musique fraîche et métissée inspirés par
leur voyage un sont gorgés d'humour et
de critique sociale que vous aurez le
plaisir d'entendre notamment le 31 mai
au scarabée à la verrière voici zoufris
maracas dans le kiosque un gamin de
gamins plus en plus tu te fais bien
j'imaginais les lignes donnent encore
une à une dans du lait sur le livre sort
que je savais combien de temps encore va
tu te balancer à 6,2 contre tu sois là
c'est du beau rendez-vous l'enduro du
petit du tracé de londres rendu fou du
méchant du corps c'est ta mère ta mère
le groupe a été formé en 2007 mais il
venait d'une association entre moi et
mon pote a fait on est parti en afrique
ensemble avec plusieurs voilà la vie
quoi talbot et puis un jour tu arrives
tu lui dis je crie chansons comme
dans mon salon
il allait chercher du boulot environ ce
type on essaie ça et puis voilà ça a
commencé comme ça
l'angoissé bahreïn afrique projeter des
films dans les villages les eaux
montaient le cinoche et ont projeté tous
les deux jours et une fois par semaine
et on faisait un bal poussière
un bal quoi et du coup pour ça on allait
dans les capitales à chaque fois de
chaque pays schouppe et toutes les
cassettes à la mode les autres passez
des heures là chez les vendeurs de
cassettes à essayer de choper des
pirates de south house how les derniers
trucs sortie là pourra voir ce qui se
passait en vie la discothèque y que tu
ailles homebrew séméac et donc comme ça
on est un peu en un peu aiguisé notre
oreille afrique nous a ouvert pas mal
est fait et de l'amérique du sud aussi
tu savais tout gérer tu me demanderais
si j'avais bien tu m'offrirait a
déchaîné
je me détacherai mains du raidillon
jusqu'à l'été prochain tu veux laisserai
vivre ici
l'aventuré free bas ça commence comme ça
là jean mach au chômedu à toulouse ce
que je bosse à greenpeace et et voilà je
me suis calé au chômage pourront changer
de ville et je commence à écrire pour
pas l'emmerder dans mon salon quoi et
donc voilà toujours on va montmartre
avec les guitares sa poule il fait beau
gling gling gling des chapeaux gamble
par sytral parent et puis les gens que
nous avons moyens mais vous êtes un
disque de rock truc là je n'aime pas
travailler debout et on a enregistré 1
une semaine un espèce de pirate
underground qui voit là et ça a commencé
comme ça où vraiment quand la fait ce
qu'elle apprendra commencé à le vendre à
droite à gauche et je me disais c'est
court mais bon après on a continué à
faire la manche pendant au moins trois
ans
qu'à 30 la loi ici sur scène
kung shin sortait un petit riff africain
pas qu'à ça nous faisait penser
africains vont triper est un peu ma
mouche parce que sanseverino évidemment
qui a marqué un peu un autre jeunesse et
du coup voilà ouais je dirais que ça va
du manouche un peu au sud américain
passant par l'afrique
tout ça avec des paroles françaises des
fois on retrouve un peu des sonorités un
peu tard elle peut renaudin des fois
c'est à la réunion que le vois je fais
prison dorée comme ça on crée à
l'imaginaire
sfr pour faire libérer mes frères c'est
tabou zealand aurais tu sais où tu peux
te la flamme
mon énervement a contribué largement en
fait que j'écrive enfin mon esprit se
passe et d'impuissance toi même ce
sentiment où tu dis merde mais en fait
moi j'avais fait des études de géo
d'environnement c'est étudié l'afrique
un peu de science mais j'ai bossé à
greenpeace
voyez un moment où je vais bourgis ça
fait dix ans un comté en main que tu
sais que tout va péter qu'est-ce que
comment ça se fait que personne ne sait
rien comment ça se fait que personne
l'entente tout le monde s'en fout
j'avais une telle masse de données que
j'ai vu il faut faire circuler qua non
je me suis dit 'pourquoi piscine en
avion alors qu'on peut faire de la
musique avec mais je me suis dit que
j'allais plus vite que ça lui c'est
aussi les gens liberté ii et puis à
force dans le temps de toutes ces
conneries à la radio ses chansons qui
disent rien
et du coup c'est un peu c'était lors la
queue qui a déclenché l'écriture on
essaie de parler de l'environnement de
la politique
les fugues et l'armée ou par les armes
aux yeux on regarde pas je ne sais quoi
t'es foutu dieu dieu du feu trop l'étude
mon flow ils vont par deux comme les
couilles qu'il me faudra pour vivre
heureux loin l'intérêt glouton droit
dans le ton jeu
les pompiers l'armée noir noeud pap
l'amour c'est pas ça s'adresse contre
que je pense intégrer quoi seul morceau
parce qu en fait j'ai quand j'écris en
général j'essaie de me faire rire toi
et comme d'ailleurs quand ça me fait
rire et que je me dis ça va taper livre
est passé bien sûr mon petit que je
connaisse enfin et tu vois la mer a
merdé grand truc tout noir devant ohno
qui fait des remous
je tiens outils et 7 mai autrefois était
plus et de danse ici dedans et tas de
bestioles à peu près comme ça est
couverte et des cas et qu'on appelle et
boissons il faut que je m'achète un
petit canta avec un chapiteau et on
monte nouvelle nous concerne on a eu
dans les champs pas comment que les
chapitres et voilà comment on prend des
bateaux on traverse
enfin ouais moi j'aimerais bien voyagé
avec la musique et faire faire ça dans
des conditions
un peu plus roots de temps en temps et
puis et puis si ça pouvait avancer sans
que je passe à la télé ça marche bien et
maintenant un nouveau sujet de la
rédaction tu es devant le soleil là
les jardins de versailles détiennent
bien des mystères entre art et
l'histoire passé et présent
nicolas jacquet guident le promeneur
vers des lieux souvent méconnu son
dernier ouvrage intitulé secrets et
curiosité des jardins de versailles se
veut explicatif mais aussi ludique
l'idée c'est quand même d'avoir une 150
pages c'est à peu près le louvre âge
avec dents sur chaque page une
explication un sens donné au symbolique
au décor qui nous entoure et c'est
donner du sens aussi au niveau des
techniques qui sont employés en fait au
fur et à mesure des balades dans le
jardin de donner du sens et d'éveiller
les sens les jardins les boss caselli
parc révèlent leurs nombreuses
symbolique
désiré par louis xiv est orchestrée par
le nôtre lebrun et hardouin mansart des
jardiniers qui ont su créer un univers
empreint de poésie et références
mythologiques célébrant la puissance
inégalable du roi soleil
c'est un endroit qui avant tout un lieu
de poésie donc à partir de là on peut
venir et questionner et s'interroger en
permanence sur les symboliques les
limites et tous univers féerique qui
nous entoure et renouveler en permanence
le regard est ce qui fait que c'est un
lieu qui est ouvert au niveau de la
lecture et on peut venir 10 x 30 x et re
découvrir de nouvelles choses est rentré
dans l'histoire par une porte qui est
quand même assez poétique
à l'heure où l'on célèbre les 400 ans de
la naissance de lenôtre
ce guide accompagnera les visiteurs pour
découvrir ou redécouvrir ces domaines
chargé d'histoire et encore deux dates à
retenir avant d'aller laver la voiture
le spectacle jeune public palette
magique sera présenté le 14 mai à la
salle jacques brel à montigny le
bretonneux tandis que la parabole mise
en scène par pascal antonini sera
proposée le 17 mai à la ferme de bel
ébat à billancourt des dates que vous
pouvez retrouver ainsi que l'ensemble de
la programmation culturelle des salles
saint-quentinoise dans le kiosque sur
internet aux adresses qui s'affiche et
en attendant sachez que tous les mardis
sur le www.caf.fr
vous pouvez gagner des places de
spectacle alors à vous de jouer